Oh
mankind has many burning questions that
we've yet to answer but perhaps none as
enticing as where did we come from
throughout our history as a sentient
species groups and cultures around the
world have sought to answer this
question and have come up with
incredibly diverse and vibrant creation
stories which deserve their own videos
and represent another branch of study
altogether in this video we'll take a
look at some of the most promising
scientific leads we have in trying to
answer the question where did life come
from we'll start with the ever-popular
primordial soup theory since its
inception in 1924 proponents of this
theory have suspected that the
biological building blocks of life could
have spontaneously come about from the
inorganic ingredients available on early
Earth this school of thought has
undergone many revisions and fallen in
and out of favor since its early stages
but the core reasoning is this early
Earth had a chemically reducing
atmosphere this atmosphere exposed to
energy in various forms produced simple
organic compounds these compounds
accumulated in a so-called soup which
may have been concentrated at various
locations such as hydrothermal vents or
shorelines by further transformation
more complex organic polymers and
ultimately life developed in the soup
probably the most important evidence for
the primordial soup theory is the famous
1952 miller-urey experiment in this
experiment grad student Stanley Miller
and professor Harold Urey simulated
early Earth conditions in the lab and
tested the chemical origin of life under
these conditions sure enough the two men
found that amino acids could indeed form
from inorganic precursors since 1952
there have been many similar studies
confirming at least the first half of
the primordial soup hypothesis the
debate now is whether these simple
building blocks could have gone on to
form early life another prominent
hypothesis is that of panspermia the
idea that life may have been seeded on
Earth by asteroid impacts this idea is a
little different in that it doesn't
attempt to explain how life originated
just how it got to earth proponents of
this hypothesis suspect that simple
extrema file life forms became trapped
in space debris after collisions between
planets and small solar system bodies
that Harbor life these organisms then
remain dormant on the long journey
through space until they crash into a
planet with ideal conditions such as
large bodies of water and the right
atmospheric content at which point the
alien life forms could begin to colonize
new environment the panspermia
hypothesis is often criticized for not
attempting to explain how this
interplanetary life came into existence
simply that it came from somewhere else
nonetheless if we were ever to discover
an asteroid that showed evidence of
primitive organic life panspermia would
have to be seriously considered and
given further study perhaps the most
promising hypothesis right now is the
thought that simple life may have
originated at deep sea hydrothermal
vents these vents are natural structures
at the bottom of the ocean that release
huge amounts of chemicals as well as
intense heat forming little oases of
warm water in an otherwise frigid
environment since sunlight can't
penetrate that far down into the dark
depths of the ocean there had to be
another source of energy for early
organisms hydrothermal vents contain a
mix of chemicals that lend themselves to
chemosynthesis a process like
photosynthesis which allows organisms to
create their own energy this hypothesis
is promising because despite the intense
heat and pressure around these vents we
always find thriving colonies of
extremophiles life this is in stark
contrast to the barren expanses of ocean
along the sea floor between hydrothermal
vents archaea thought to be the most
primitive domain of organisms thrive in
the conditions offered by these deep-sea
oases which bodes well for the
hydrothermal vent hypothesis scientists
have traced the DNA of all living things
back to a common ancestor that could
likely have been found at these sites
the hypothesis speculates that over time
these primitive organisms slowly changed
and evolved into more complex forms
eventually leading to life as we know it
today this is one of the newer
hypotheses trying to answer the question
of where life came from but it seems
very promising the most exciting part
about the hydrothermal vent hypothesis
is that we could be well on our way to
proving this was the origin of life on
Earth but also elsewhere in the universe
Jupiter's icy moon Europa is home to
incredible thermal activity it's so
promising that we're sending a probe
there in the near future to fly through
it's amazing plumes and collect samples
to test for life Europa has a thick icy
shell which covers an enormous global
ocean its proximity to Jupiter stretches
and relaxes its surface generating
energy and hydrothermal activity deep
beneath the icy crust
if these hydrothermal vents are similar
to Earth's we might not only find life
on Europa
but life not entirely unlike that on
earth
Europa is about four and a half billion
years old about the same age as Jupiter
if this hydrothermal activity has been
going on for even half that time and the
protective icy shell has shielded its
ocean from potential threats the life we
find on Europa might not be so simple
and if we do find life on this icy moon
regardless of complexity it will all but
prove the hydrothermal vent hypothesis
on earth while there are plenty of other
hypotheses about the origins of life on
Earth these three represent the most
popular and possibly the most promising
explanations but until we can say for
certain why we're here this remains
perhaps the greatest question humanity
has ever asked what do you think where
did life come from let us know your
thoughts in the comments below remember
to click that subscribe button if you
enjoyed this video and click the little
bell to be notified every time I upload
a new video you can watch my other space
related content by clicking here or if
you're really bored you can binge watch
all my content by clicking here
then come unwind and watch me play video
games very poorly on my gaming channel
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next week